A LOCAL COUPLE BATTLING
COVID-19 AT THE SAME TIME.
DOCTORS ADMITTED THE HUSBAND AND
AND SHE'S ALMOST 7 MONTHS
PREGNANT.
THE I-TEAM'S DAVID CHARNS
HERE NOW WITH THEIR STORY.
((DAVID CHARNS))
MELISSA DIEP
SAYS SHE AND HER HUSBAND WERE
THEY BOTH GOT COVID...
AND SHE'S 26 WEEKS PREGNANT WITH
A ONE YEAR OLD AT HOME.
((MELISSA DIEP: :
MAMA HAS NO ENERGY
TODAY, AND IT'S SO HARD TO TALK,
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW, I LOVE
YOU.
:19)) ((DAVID CHARNS))
SHE SENT THAT MESSAGE TO
HER SON FROM HER HOSPITAL BED AT
MOUNTAIN-VIEW.
HER HUSBAND -- ALSO AT THE
HOSPITAL.
THEY'RE BOTH 37 YEARS OLD.
SHE DESCRIBES THE EXPERIENCE AS
EXTREMELY ISOLATING -- BUT
CREDITS HER FAITH WITH KEEPING
HER SPIRITS UP.
((MELISSA DIEP // COVID
SURVIVOR: 4:51 COVID IS SO
STRANGE.
ONE DAY YOU'RE FEELING BETTER.
LIKE YESTERDAY HE WAS ON A HIGH.
HE WAS SO ENERGETIC.
WE HAD A GREAT TIME CATCHING UP
ON VIDEO.
AND THEN
TODAY HE JUST FEELS SO WEAK.
5:02))
((DAVID CHARNS))
YOU CAN SEE THERE SHE'S
STILL ON OXYGEN.
HER HUSBAND REMAINING AT THE
HOSPITAL NOW.
((DAVID CHARNS))
WHEN WE SEE YOU AT SIX --
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT WHY SHE
DELAYED GETTING THE VACCINE --
AND WHY DOCTORS SAY YOU
SHOULDN'T WORRY IF YOU'RE
PREGNANT.
I'M DAVID CHARNS 8 NEWS NOW.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))